Hello and welcome to fire of learning.
My name is Justin and I run the channel.
We are essentially an educational or
edutainment channel. What's our focus?
Well, quite honestly, we're open to
talking about all kinds of subjects,
but our main focus is on
history, the sciences, sociology,
languages in subjects like what we
talk about in videos like these.
And I'd like to think that these videos
are only the beginning and as you can
see, not only do we talk
about a variety of topics,
but also in a variety of lengths.
Sometimes it's a quick rundown.
Other times I spent a good while
covering a subject and its entirety.
What makes fire of learning unique among
other channels? Well, a few things. One,
I leave my beliefs out
of my videos. Why? Well,
I could do a whole video
on why and I likely will.
But the main reason is that it's not
my place to tell you how to think,
only to give you things to think about.
Not that I don't ever share any opinions,
but my politics, social
views, religion, all of that I
leave out too. It's all free.
And it always will be. If you
wanted to support us on our Patrion,
that'd be great. But if not, you'll
still have access to everything.
I produce three,
I cover whole subjects,
but I tried to make them straight forward
and easy to understand without leaving
the good stuff out. And if it's
not easy to understand, no worries.
Because for I listened to you guys, I read
the comments, I get, I respond to you,
I pull you on your opinions,
that kind of thing.
So if this sounds interesting to you,
I'd invite you to come check us
out and subscribed by the way,
because it covers so many topics.
I tried to keep it organized in my
playlist section to help you navigate the
channel. Also, I like to think that I've
gotten better at making videos over time.
So maybe start with the newer stuff.
Thanks everyone.